okay welcome everyone to this webinar
uh we will talk today about
the genomic analysis of stars cove
two new variants in uh
this time when the vaccine is starting
to be administered all over the world
and so what we want to do is we want to
just discuss some of the
variants that are appearing and what are
some of the biological factors behind
this
and uh first of all um let me introduce
our first speaker so dr
kasulist who is the head of department
of pathobiological sciences
and uh he's also the director of the
division of biotechnology and molecular
medicine
biomen at the school of veterinary
medicine at the louisiana state
university in baton rouge in louisiana
and he is also the principal
investigator of louisiana biomedical
research
network lbrn and the president of the
national association of idea principal
investigators navy so gus
i will pass it over to you okay
thank you elia let me share my screen
okay i hope everybody sees my screen
right now
uh eli let me know if there's an issue
yeah we can see your screen but we don't
see the full slide we see i think the
presenter
view oh this is potentially an issue
that we've never resolved here um
you see
if i put on the presentation mode that's
where it goes
um so i just wonder
if there's a trick that you know uh
uh yeah down there yeah down there if
you
i think uh you see you know keep go back
to that screen real quick
okay in the presenter mode
in the presenter mode and on top
you see you have end show tips and then
swap displays
so click on swap displays it's on the
top left corner
okay swap this place there we go
now we can see the right view you did it
okay all right
that's good to know okay well um
thank you everybody for attending uh
thank you for the
introduction what are we gonna try to do
today
is give you a glimpse um perhaps
on what is going on now for all these
new variants that have been appearing
worldwide
and we hope that this introduction is
in sort of an introduction of a couple
different things that we're doing with
the louisiana biomedical research
network
as well as with lsu we
uh have formulated the graduate course
pbs 7003 section two
that will be starting somewhere
mid-february
concentrating on analysis tools
bioinformatics tools
for looking at sequences from simple
alignments all the way
to structural prediction and looking at
some of the topics that we'll be
discussing today
also in addition uh in collaboration
with find biotech and uh leibrozzi that
was our organizer for this webinar
we're going to be offering a cadre of
different
bioinformatics courses that will be
virtually delivered
through the lbr network and it will be
underwritten
by a brn for those that belong to the
lbrn
network and we hope that blind bartek
will also extend the discount
for others that may be relating uh
indirectly to
our network one way or the other so um
i want to do a brief introduction to the
topic uh some time ago
i gave a full hour lecture on the
molecular and cellular biology
of such cov2 and coronaviruses
specifically
and that lecture has been taped it was
as
in fact two-hour lecture because we had
my
lecture up front and eli brodsky gave
the second part of the lecture
where we did a very detailed analysis of
the molecular cell biology
of charles cove ii and that lecture is
taped and is available
i believe on the lbrn network for those
that may want to
hear more of the specifics of the
molecular cell biology
and other tools that have been used to
analyze
those genomes and the structures
of the predictive structures of
different proteins so
as an introduction today what i want to
do is focus specifically
and highlight the uh possibility
in fact the actuality that coronaviruses
are really more error prone that people
think
because there's a lot of
misunderstanding discussing the fact
that
the rna depending on polymerase that's
important for the replication of the
virus
has proofreading activity therefore the
genomes
shouldn't really be that variant but in
fact as you'll see
and we'll be discussing that this
coronaviruses exist as a swarm
a quasi species a complex set of
different types of our strains
that could then be selected based on
immune selection
or antiviral therapy and so on so what
we see
and the take-home message is what we see
now are these emerging variants
is not really a surprise it's just
basically the interaction of the virus
with the host
uh perhaps even the additional pressure
that we're putting
on this quasi species with these
vaccines
that ultimately uh selected variants
would be
selected replicating at higher level and
we can see either increased
pathogenicity
or hopefully in the long run it
decreased pathogenicity as the virus
evolves and adapts to the host so in
brief then
um i've done that introduction in the
past i just want to remind you
that corona starts viruses are not
particularly new to us right now
we had the severe acute respiratory
syndrome back in 2002
also from uh from uh china originated
belonged to the beta coronavirus group
it was also transmitted from bats to
civets and civics was the intermediate
host
to humans we had an outbreak of more
than 8
000 cases 774 deaths and fatality rate
of 9.6
so this virus was quite lethal
but it did not spread very well and that
has to do
with the receptors that the virus was
using at the time
she was very quickly contained and we
didn't have major
epidemics epidemics we also have the
cousin virus the middle east respiratory
syndrome virus maris another coronavirus
is
2012 or even in saudi arabia again the
same group of
viruses it was transmitted from camels
to humans more than 2 400 cases
858 deaths and a fatality rate of 34.4
very lethal virus again it was very
quickly
uh isolated because the transmissions
were also known in muscle cameo
in hospital settings and uh
they were very easily contained because
the virus was not easily transmissible
and now we have the 2019 coronavirus
susco 2
that appeared in china and it's the
seventh coronavirus found to cause venus
in humans mind you we have four other
human coronaviruses
that are really a seasonal so every year
15 to 20 percent of respiratory
infections are caused by this already
pre-existing coronaviruses
in fact there is a hypothesis that
perhaps exposure to these viruses
may in fact
prevent subsequent at least lethal
infection but that has not been proven
yet so i wanted to also tell you
that not only as we will discuss that
the replication machinery of these
viruses create quasi species and
variants
that could be ultimately selected but
the actual pull of those viruses
in bats and this is the different types
of viruses we've seen
from different vectors uh and the
coronaviruses have originated from bats
and the cells cove too
the the over 400 genotypes of
suscov related viruses in bats right now
that have been catalogued mainly from
china
and we don't know what other type of
coral bars exist in bats elsewhere
so there is not only ability of the
virus to
alter itself during its replication
cycle
but also the fact that there is a
plethora of these types of viruses
different genotypes already pre-existing
uh giving the possibility that any of
these viruses could emerge
to be a pathogenic viruses virus in
humans
we also know a lot about coronaviruses
um
from other coronaviruses that affect
humans
and you can see here a number of
different coronaviruses of the uh
older category of different groups one
two three
alpha beta gamma and ultimately the
delta group and you have the human
coronal virus the twenty and e in the
alpha group but we have also
transmissible gastroenterovirus
porcine coronavirus uh the feline
infections peritonitis virus very
little in cats and canine carnovarus and
others
and of course under the beta group we
have the mouse hepatitis virus
and myoscapatitis virus is actually a
coronavirus
that very accurately depicts the
symptoms and disease patterns of
human uh stress co2 virus in mice in
fact there is a very nice
model for studying
the immunopathobiology of coronaviruses
in the mouse system and
um also and these viruses have been
extensively studied
uh their tropics most of them are
respiratory but also enteric
they can alter between respiratory and
etheric as we see also for sarsa cof2
as you're familiar with from all the
news that had
any publications that have transpired so
far
so against us cove too the new virus
affects humans there's some indications
that may affect certain animals but uh
not really at the level whether it would
be used for uh transmission
um and then we have respiratory mostly
infection but also enteric
a multi-organ infection at some point
including neurological tissues and
neurological
symptoms are created because of
subsequent suscope to infection
so uh in our lab we've worked also in
bovine coronaviruses respiratory
coronary
coronaviruses
and that's where a number of papers in
the early 2000s
late 90s we described the quasi species
and we really discussed the fact that
the unique replication
and transcriptional studies of
chronoviruses may be causing in vivo
generation or viral quasi species that
is these variants that
ex exist and can be selected upon uh
different pressure in fact for bovine
coronaviruses the distinct genotypes
that affect the
mostly respiratory or mostly enteric and
most likely the hypothesis for us at
that point was
that the acute respiratory disease
syndrome in cattle
was really caused by bovine respiratory
coronovirus
that then was followed by pastel
hemolytic
infection which is a bacterial infection
and this is exactly what we see now
in saskatchewan infections
so if we look very briefly on the life
cycle of the coronaviruses
the virus is an envelope virus it has a
glycoprotein
a major spike like a protein on the
surface this is the one that really
binds the receptors
at different receptors really determines
the host range of the virus
the virus then will enter through
endocytosis it will fuse out of the
endosome
and then it will be ready for
replication
the replication of the plus strand rna
so the rna is
an mrna polarity which is actually
capped in poly8 at the very end
and it goes through a negative sense
anti-genome
uh replicative intermediate and then
from there on you have sub-genomic
messages all those really
uh use a negative dna intermediate to
produce sub-genomic mrnas
and this is one of the mechanisms where
mutations are created in fact
the level of variance at the mrna
at the replicative intermediates is much
higher than what you see
on the viral genome because by the time
they
replicate and embed it into the genome
there's proofreading activity
and stability selection to select a
virus that would be
stable in terms of replication
properties
so this is uh for monster but that is
virus but uh
out of um uh virology textbook
and you can see the fact that uh you
have up to 31
uh 526 nucleotides they
typically and i'll discuss later for
susco2
you have approximately 14 to 15
different operating frames coding for
over 27 different proteins
and that enhanced the protein content is
because of proteolytic cleavage
the virus called zone48 and brought here
that
process different proteins to create
more active functional
subsequences of proteins and also
um uh it uses as i said earlier the
different types of rnas
that the five prime three prime
coterminal having the poly a tail and
the five prime m
of the uh genome sequence and this is
done through a discontinuous replication
where basically
during the negative intermediate the
polymerase jumps
at the end of that sequence through uh
regulatory sequences
and adds the five prime sequence and
that specific phenomenon
is actually error prone and
this is the 2019 uh viral
genome for source cup 2 again as i said
14 operating frames
27 different proteins another mechanism
to increase the
protein content is ribosomal shifting
slipping where basically during the
polymerase here you could have a
ribosomal shift and produce different
types of proteins
the major spike proteins is the
fusogenic protein that determines host
range
because it has the binding domain for
different types of receptors
but also importantly enough the virus
encodes a number of different other
proteins non-structural proteins some of
them are structural
like the e-protein and then protein and
then while these are non-structural
and have important and yet most of
mostly
unknown functions uh regulating innate
immune response and that's
also pretty important because some of
the variants that we see
are not only in receptor binding or
determining constraints
but some of the nucleotide and amino
acid changes may be
in some of these proteins that relate to
how the virus controls the innate
immune response and that subsequent
downstream adaptive immune response
so um i think elia would elaborate
further
uh this importance of the spike protein
the spike protein
is the only fusiogenic protein that
determines the viral entry
binding onto receptors and fusion
it uh we know that the s1 domain
that contains the receptor binding
domain
determines tissue tropism and it's
it's sensitive to different ph
conformations in order for this
fused genie proteins the type 1 class 1
viral fusion proteins to
exert their membrane fusion ability they
have to really open
up exposing a fusion peptide which then
intercalates in the opposite membrane
creates
a pore function where the trimer
assembles uh
to create that pore and that results in
fusion of their viral envelope with
cellular membranes
during exocytosis from the endosome or
in certain other viruses during entry at
the plasma membrane
and of course the spike protein is the
major immunogenic
protein the antigen and this is used
extensively in the vaccines that we'll
discuss briefly here
then again what i mentioned as a
mechanism for entry you have the
viral spike protein attaching to a
receptor potential of the core receptors
then you have a conformational change
and ultimately exposes the fusion
peptide here in red
uh to the approachment brain and then
the primary is reassembled
in the opposed membrane to create the
pore
to mediate the membrane fusion
phenomenon that
results in the viral capsid freeing
into the cytoplasm of infected cells
again
in terms of receptors i mentioned the
fact that we know a lot about the
different receptors we know that some of
these viruses
transmission has gastroenterovirus uses
the porcine
epn molecule the
different other molecules that will
actually use that too
but it will also have your embryonic
antigen m1
for muscle but that is virus would be
well characterized as well as the
as a core receptor the in uh all linked
acetyl
gluck so this receptors that bind into
these different receptors really as i
said
the host range of the virus and
phosphorus co2
we know now that it uses the angiotensin
ii h2 receptor
and in fact it contains additional
elements for
efficient proteolytic cleavage and
exposure of the fusion peptide
that's why this virus is quite efficient
in infection
as well as spread
and we know that uh from our animal
studies
the deletions of the spike protein uh
can change or amino acids can change
virulence and tissue
proposition one specific example is
transmissible
and gastroenteritis virus which is
really an enteric very high
uh pathogenic enteric disease in piglets
but if you delete
225 amino acids from the amino terminus
from this
s1 amino terminal portion of spike you
create the porcine coronavirus which
only causes mild respiratory disease of
pigs
and some interstitial pneumonia so we
know that the spike protein its receptor
binding ability in its physiogenic
functions are very important in terms of
this pathogenicity
we also i want to highlight these two
papers that we published back
in 2005 and 2007 for such call one
with chad petit who is now an associate
professor at the
university of alabama in birmingham and
the only thing
i wanted to tell you is that we found
that not only mutations as would you
expect in the uh the extracellular
portion of spike
but also mutations of the carboxy
terminus of the
spike glycoprotein would affect the
physiogenic ability and
binding and functions of the receptors
so it's not necessarily that you have
mutations only
in the binding or perhaps fusion peptide
but they could be distal
and through conformational changes alter
the function of the protein
altering its horse strains and perhaps
its ability to
uh infect efficiently and spread
we recently in collaboration with dr c
rama joyce at
ulm we published this paper and i
borrowed one figure from that
what we did we took the spike protein of
the susco one
and which is called sars old
and the sus spike protein of the susco
two pneum
and we expressed it transiently in uh
african green monkey cells
and then we stained them uh for
expression and we wanted to see if the
different proteins
express uh cause different types of cell
to cell fusion
which is indication of the ability of
the spike protein to really
facilitate more efficient entry as well
spread from cell to cell
through a cell to cell fusion mechanism
as you can see the old one
causes limited fusion or african green
microcells viral cells here
although the new cells called two virus
causes extensive fusion
and this is also a a property of the
virus that is not
frankly paid much attention in the
literature
because this virus not only enters more
efficiently
through a enhanced physiogenic ability
of the spike protein
but also can spread from cell to cell by
fusing adjacent cells
that is then you could potentially have
a high level neutralizing antibody
in your lung fluids but in reality the
virus can spread from cell to cell
without necessarily seeing the
extracellular space
so uh i wanted to bring your attention
again to the accessory proteins
uh for uh the sales cov2 although they
uh have similarities to subscribe one
and such go to
there are also differences and some of
the pathogenic potential of subscribe to
maybe relating and depending on some of
these proteins that
regulate the immune system and if you
look at the functions that have been
predicted
and again we don't know a lot about all
these proteins
you can see that a number of these
proteins relate
to innate immune responses for instance
3a
is incorporated with virulent particles
and upregulates enough capobera
il8 aurantis and so on it has also a
role in apoptosis induction and cycles
arrest
3b uh we don't know if it's incorporated
into a particle but it has a type one
affects type one interferon production
and signaling inhibition
again six and so on type interferon
production
and um uh ab cell dna synthesis caspase
independent cell death
apoptosis and anti-apoptotic functions
so the
um if then it's easy to see and project
that some of these proteins would be
very important in how their virus deals
with the innate immune response evading
the innate immune response
and any other defense mechanism
including apoptosis
that the cells may have in order to
really be successful as an infectious
pathogen
so i wanted to focus uh on the new
variants and try to make some
extrapolations as a background to what
julia brodsky will be talking about and
this is really from the
central disease control pages
practically the button
as we know we have the um that's been
all over in the news now the b117
lineage
uh which is the very of concern because
uh
it's been hypothesized that uh not
necessarily more
lethal but apparently up to 50 or higher
more transmissible and yet we don't know
exactly what that means
but that's been mostly on some clinical
data
and anecdotal evidence as opposed to
real experiments that
could really be subject to peer review
the variant has a mutation in the
receptor binding domain of the spike at
position 501
and amino acid asparagine has been
replaced with tyrosine
so this shorthand for this mutation is
n51y
that you see in the literature and the
variant also has several other mutations
including
a deletion of two amino acids that occur
spontaneously
and like leads to conformational changes
in the spike protein
and the mutation of proline 68 to
histidine
here the s112 fury included site and
that hearing site is really processing
the s1 s2
cleavage to facilitate exposure
diffusion peptide
and increase futurism there's also a
stop codon or
on our fate and this function is
unknown the variant was estimated to
have first emerged in the uk
uh since december 20th there are several
countries not have reported cases of
b117
including the united states and canada
first reported in colorado
and california as well now apparently
in new york the variance associated with
increased transmissibility more
efficient and said rapid transmission
and there's no evidence so far to
suggest that this variant has any impact
on the severity of disease or vaccine
efficacy however it's noted that the uh
now the population has been affected
increasingly are younger populations so
perhaps this increased
transmission has something to do with
this that gets transmitted
more efficiently into a younger uh
patients the second one is the b151
lineage the
this particular virus has multiple
mutations in the spike protein including
uh the this mutations indicated here in
red
but i'd like to be one on seven linux so
it's detected in
uk this variant does not contain the
deletion of 6970
that i noted earlier this was actually
identified in south africa
uh in samples back beginning october 20
and cases have been uh detected outside
of south africa
the the varian was also identified in
zambia
and currently there's no evidence
suggested this variant has any impact on
disease severity
there is some evidence to indicate
though that one of the spike protein
mutations the e484k
may affect neutralization by some
polyclonal and monoclonal antibodies
and that would be the expectation based
on the fact that
this horse these viruses have gone
through hosts that mount their own
immune responses
not necessarily be subject to monoclonal
body therapy
or any of the vaccines they may already
be selected as immune escape variants
and the last one i'll mention that is
also mentioned in cdc
is the uh this particular p1 lineage
the mutation that's shown here and this
one
is uh has 17 unique
amino acids and three deletions and
contains these mutations
there's no evidence that just some of
these mutations in the p1 variant may
affect the transmissibility
uh an ethogenic profile so far
but a recent study reported on a cluster
of these cases
in mount house the largest city in the
amazon region um
and in this region it is estimated
approximately 75 percent of the
population
have been infected with subscribe too as
october 2020
and perhaps this high level of
infectivity led
to this variant being selected much
quicker than it would be in other parts
of the of the
world the emergence of this variant
raises substantial concerns of a
potential increase in transmissibility
or propensity for susceptible infections
of individuals
because of the plethora of these
mutations and deletions
across the genome they
uh obviously what are the potential
consequences of heaven's virus you could
see that in red and i'll go fairly
briefly on that
uh the ability to spread more quickly in
people we've seen this
there's already evidence that one
mutation that
the 60 60 14 to g glycine mutation
confers increased ability to spread more
quickly than the wild type virus
uh this particular variant uh propagates
more quickly in human respiratory
material cells in cell culture
outcompeting the 614d original
multiviruses
there's also epidemiological evidence
that the 614 g variant spreads more
quickly
than viruses without imitation the other
consequence would be ability to cause
other milder or more severe disease in
people
so far there is no evidence that these
recently identified core viruses
cause more severe disease than the early
ones other than the fact that there is a
strong
indication or suspicion that this virus
is transmitted more efficiently
the ability to evade detection by
specific diagnostic tests is of concern
most commercial polymerase and reaction
tests have multiple targets though
to detect the virus as the ones that we
use here for wastewater
detection in our laboratory for these
variation of the shoe
so basically by having multiple sets of
pcr primers
you would avoid the fact that maybe you
uh
you'll be unable to detect a specific uh
variant and but that needs to be looked
at every time a variant comes in
because it's possible by accident that
the pcr primers that
are selected really target those altered
mutations which case you won't be able
to see that
oops decreased susceptibility to
therapeutic agents as monoclonal
antibodies
obviously if you had targets of
monoclonal antibodies like monoclinal
body therapy
which president trump was treated with
if there is that area
where the uh the single amino acid
change could really knock out
the monolith body therapy fairly easily
an ability to evade natural
vaccine-induced immunity and that's
where basically these
other open-ready frames are very
important and mutations because we
do not understand the immunopathogenesis
of these viruses
so everybody's concentrating on the
spike protein because the easier target
but in reality there are many other
things that we need to know of how this
virus really controls
the immune response and causes
pathogenicity
uh in terms of vaccines very quickly i
wanted to just give you a
you know 30 000 mile uh view of
vaccinology
we've been working on vaccines for
quantum viruses quite some time
successfully in many a number of
instances unsuccessfully
we have live attenuated vaccines or
foreseen
endemic disease virus uh and that's been
done by
serial passage of the virus 90 times or
more
in african green monkey cells the
infectious bronchitis virus it has
multiple serotypes
and there are vaccines for ebv right now
so with a similar type of mechanism
we have killed vaccines that have been
used
for canine coronary virus and infectious
bronchitis virus
don't not us successfully but at least
they provide some
protection and there are vector vaccines
including adrenal virus vaccines
for lactogenic immunity to transmissible
gastroenterology virus
and pacquiao virus for the spike smn
that has been used for preventing
etheric
challenges there's also passive
immunization using neutralization of
antibodies as already has been used for
cells co2 and at the end up in the body
dependent enhancement
with uh feline coronavirus vaccines
so for cover dive team vaccines that are
in human trials and
already been out there in the market as
you know
mrna 1273 for moderna
is really the uh the entire spike
protein at least the entire
extracellular portion of the spike
protein
uh it has passed the phase three is
actually in the market it requires
two doses uh 28 days apart
and uh has been shown to be uh 94 to 95
percent efficacious in terms of
preventing the disease onset
the mrna bnt 162 pfizer
it has only uh the rbd the receptor
binding domain
linked to a fibrin neck that facilitates
standardization
and so basically it's a much smaller
target in terms of that chain
and that similarly has passed the phase
three trials and
that creates a single or two doses that
uh
administrator a few weeks apart we have
a number of other vaccines that are
coming
into play we have the novio
pharmaceutical link
there's a dna plasmid we have the jensen
pharmaceutical companies
johnson johnson as an adenovirus 5
vector
vaccine and oxford university which has
the zenica
in collaboration with the russian
company uh with sputnik which is the
vaccine adenovaccine
they use a simian vector to express the
spike protein for vaccine purposes
and they report 50 to 90 percent
efficacy also for this
and those would be are in the market
already uh at least the admin viral
vectors are in the market
um and then again this is something
about
uh why uh the docents here you could see
that the moderna you have
up to 100 uh really micrograms
of pertoss that's a lot of rna which is
big codon optimized and includes
specific ribonucleotide nucleotides that
are being
placed as uh synthetic there to down
regulate the immune response recognition
by tlr3
tlr4 and tilo7 because rna in itself is
very inflammatory
and in fact in certain patients in
germany and elsewhere or accidentally
were given five times the dose
that severe problems inflammatory
response anaphylactic shock
and so on uh they have different
requirements being frozen or not
and the the the fisa vaccine
requires a minus 70 degrees because
really it's a much smaller protein and
the need to preserve the trimer
otherwise it falls apart although the
moderna has the entire spike that
naturally forms a primer and those both
the modernic has a nih-driven mutation
nothing like we'll talk about this that
keeps the spike protein
in an open conformation exposing the rpd
domain
to increase the ability to create
neutralizing antibodies
against the rpd domain i want to also
tell you that
we know in the past for uh sars called
one
that neutralizing antibodies and memory
b cell responses are short-lived
in cells recovery patients in human
patients and you can see here
that is under these patients that is the
cohort itself in black
patient a patient b that over time uh
in months you can see that the immune
response the b cell responds anybody
responds to be
weighing out and the question is
although the studies have been done
two to three months right now it will be
very interesting to see what the results
are
six months uh down the road whether you
know b
and t cell responses are really
surviving
and they're not weighing out and whether
those people have been vaccinated or
protected in the long term
so this is what i wanted to tell you in
brief
if i want to sort of uh quickly
summarize before i recognize my stuff
here
is that uh two things uh suscov
uh genotypes exist as a plethora of
genotypes
in paths right now over 400 genotypes
in addition the replication machine of
this coronaviruses
creates this uh quasi species
these variants in cell culture that
could be easily selected
based on external stimulus and external
selection
whether that would be an antiviral or a
immune selection so it's not surprising
then
that we could see variants evolving
these variants were not really
caused by mutational rates of the rdp
polymerase
although that also could play into this
but it could be
also pre-existing as part of the quasi
species that are naturally selected
in fact the thing elia would mention a
recent paper where
they took the virus subscribe to and
they put it in cell culture in the
presence of human antibody
and they have selected variants very
easily that mimic some of the virus that
we've seen
so far so we're really at the beginning
understanding how these viruses evolve i
think bioinformatic
analysis is extremely important because
as we see these variants are coming
through
and maybe even detected them ahead as
part of the quasi species
we could potentially predict the outcome
of these variants which one would
persist
or create a different pathogenic profile
so i want to thank you for your
attendance and i want to acknowledge
people in my lab the uh
general general medical neurology cover
uh
and paper on nelfina beer the difference
between spike
proteins for subscribe one and two were
worked
by dr fahana muserat and dr vladimir
jenko also everybody else in the lab has
contributed to a lot of the work that
we're doing so far
including some of our vaccine efforts
that are ongoing
we have in the lab adenoviral vectors
and
herpes vectors that express spike
protein
and we're actively involved in vaccine
experiments and of course
all our collaborators and acknowledge
the collaboration with lybrotsky
and the october bioinformatics research
center at the university of haifa
which is really where elia originated at
least the company got spun off
from the october center so thank you and
we can proceed then
elia with your presentation unless there
are some questions at this point
i know how you want to handle that
thank you guys yeah so i imagine that
some people might have questions about
your presentation so we'll just
if you have any questions please put
them in the chat
we will address them maybe towards the
end of
my part of the presentation which is not
going to be very long
so um again if you have any questions
and thank you guys for the presentation
please
put those in the chat
um so what i wanted to do is kind of
pick up on some of these topics and
expand a little bit
to talk about the bioinformatic aspect
of how we can piece together this data
where does the biology or the biological
understanding of this virus intersect
with the data that is available and that
is being generated daily
and how do we piece together the whole
puzzle to kind of think about
the impact of this rollout of the
vaccines
and the impact of how
diverse the virus will eventually become
as these additional treatments are
introduced and being used more widely
so as gus already mentioned
many of the vaccines and early research
on coronaviruses and source cove 2
primarily has been focused on this key
role of the spike protein which plays an
important role in
zoonotic transmission and in general
in cell entry and so when we look at the
source code ii genome you can see it's
encoded right here
in this region and what it does is
it has this particular property
that it actually is formed by these two
subunits and those are cleaved
so that the s1 subunit can
attach to the membrane so what you can
see here
is the significance of some of those
terms that
gus was using throughout his part of the
lecture uh the receptor binding domain
and different parts of this spike
glycoprotein so
what has happened since then is that
there has been a
continuation of uh data collected
from these different studies and so here
we see an excellent example of
how structurally people have started to
understand
um the way that this protein works and
so what was done in the study
is that this spike glycoprotein
was captured connected to the virion
itself
and you can see that the virion actually
contains
both of these conformations so you can
see
that in general has two forms the thin
structure
that resembles this needle-like
post-fusion structure
and then the wider one which is the
pre-fusion structure
and when they captured this intact
virion about
97 were pre-fusion and about three
percent were post-fusing
um and about 25
in total per virion the researchers also
examined
the thin and the wide trimer shapes and
found that they showed
a very interesting correspondence so we
don't know everything about how this
works in real life
but this kind of data really allows us
to see
um this structure intact and so
what is interesting about the structure
is that it's not static it's not always
kind of protruded outward but it
actually
can be found in many of these so it's
kind of shaking right so you can see
right here
that perhaps it's uh kind of dynamic um
and so it also could be in multiple
ways either open closed to open
uh three closed one open right so
there's a variety of shapes that you can
expect here
so to really understand how this
connects with the genomic data
i think it's important to appreciate
that
data the majority of the data that we
have is actually genomic sequencing data
and so the genomic sequencing data
when it is pieced together with this
kind of an understanding of the
structure of these proteins
it really provides a lot of insight i
think into
how we can understand what's going on so
here you can see this
s1 subunit on top the s2 sub unit on the
bottom
and here's a little video of what
happens if you
detach the top part so it's like a cap
that's sitting on top
and the reason i'm showing this is
because i think once we go into the
specific mutations it becomes very
interesting when you
think about how does this practically
work
so um when
originally the major question was
about the origin of this coronavirus
and i guess explained it in great detail
one of the major findings during that
time
was that the novel coronavirus was
very similar to one of the bad
coronaviruses that was captured not
long before the human version was
sequenced and so um one of the questions
would be well what is difference
between bats and humans
that so many different viruses that end
up
uh becoming endemic or pandemic
acquire these properties so how does
that environment really play a role
in what happens and so one of the things
that you see here
you probably already recognize that the
majority of these mutations that are
differences essentially between the rad
g13 genome and the human coca-19 genome
are found in this receptor binding
domain region
but also if we look overall how
these relate to other bad coronaviruses
and other
stars like coronaviruses we can see that
there are
very specific properties um that have
been
um acquired through this transformation
and so one of the questions
that was posed in this paper was what is
so
unique about bats that kind of
you know puts them in the center of all
of these pandemics
and so um on it i'll provide evidence
that
one mechanism bats have evolved to limit
excessive inflammation during viral
infection
is to dampen transcriptional priming and
lower functional capacity of the bad
inflammasome
sensor you know our family pyrin domain
containing
three um which is
nor p3 and it functions as a pathogen
recognizing receptor to activate
inflammatory mediators so
this inflammation has also been linked
to aging and age-related chronic
diseases
and the study provides a mechanism for
and a provisional answer to whether bats
have evolved to tolerate or resist viral
infections so this work really suggests
that bats have adapted to tolerate viral
infection
without development of pathology through
inflammation
which explains essentially that
the virus can replicate
in a bat without leaving the same host
for long periods of time in fact i think
in this paper
it was mentioned that it could be
several months
that the virus replicates continuously
inside the bat
and this is very different from the
types of hosts that
do show inflammation
that have a kind of acute disease
and as a result of both the pressure
that the virus is under and the long
time
that it can uh kind of exist in a single
host
makes it a unique situation where many
novel
uh mutations recombination um and
properties are acquired so to understand
some of these properties
right we started talking about the
different domains
and so one of these regions in
the receptor binding domain which you
can see here on top
is really the binding to the ace2
receptor and so it's easy to kind of
imagine how
because of this evolutionary pressure
for the virus to escape
this high pressure environment in the
bat find
new hosts eventually it is able to
primarily kind of adapt to these novel
phase ii variants that are found in
other hosts
and so what we can see in this original
kind of those mutations that we were
looking at right is that those mutations
are
very close to that binding so again this
is a trimer so you can see here three
times it's the same thing is replicated
and only one of the receptor
binding domains is open and so you can
see the ace2 the portion of the h2 that
is bound to this receptor
so when we look at these mutations
they're found specifically
in that portion so now the question is
right so this was about the origin and
this was about the question well how did
the virus acquire the certain properties
how was it introduced into the human
population and so now we have
a lot more information about what
happened after that
so essentially if we look now this was
taken
yesterday i think so this is from next
train
a website that displays genomic
information collected from around the
world
and analysis of that genomic information
to understand the relationship between
the different clades that are emerging
and what you can see here is first of
all
how the different clades are divided up
throughout the world
on the website itself you can see a nice
animation of how the viral
strains kind of originated from
different places and that's essentially
the goal of this analysis here on the
side is to demonstrate
how individual dots which are samples
are representative of different clades
and so you can see a phylogenetic tree
and if you see here on top there is a
total of
uh 12 plates right so right here if you
just count these up there's a total of
12 clades now what's interesting
is that this is showing essentially one
year so from
january 2020 to january 2021
you can see how for a variety of reasons
really
there has been a gradual increase in the
number
of clearly defined clades so you can see
here we've got three up until about
february
and then we have about five here until
may and then
about seven to eight kind of emerge over
this period of time because one of them
kind of disappears
almost and then today we're looking at
10 kind of major clades that are known
and then
here if you actually count all of these
you can see that some of them
are very minor right so some of them are
either emerging
just like we saw here so some of them
are emerging and growing in number
or some of them could be just kind of
coming appearing and disappearing
and so the reason i'm showing this is
because
we now have this tremendous collection
of genomic
information on one hand it allows us to
analyze the data and understand both the
origin
and the dynamics of this disease as it
spreads
on the other hand it is also limited due
to
a variety of biases for example we know
that most of these samples are collected
in areas of
outbreak right so if there's not an
outbreak we don't have any information
a lot of the sequencing also happens
around the major outbreaks
and so we do expect this
data to be informative but also some of
the questions could be limited but some
information is already emerging
that is going to be very interesting for
us to look at today
so for example one of the things that if
we
do the exact same thing on this
next train website you can zoom in and
you can look at
how specific proteins acquire mutation
so at what
rate do they acquire mutation so an
interesting thing would be
to look at the spike protein just like
we were looking in terms of the
zoonotic transmission and ask the
question well
how are these mutations distributed
throughout this
protein so you can see here this is the
spiked protein so it's about
21 600 to about 25
400 that's the length of this
gene and here you can see the s1 subunit
and the s2 subunit
and so it's fairly clear that the s1
subunit
has many more mutations that we can
observe right here and so here we do
have some mutations but
essentially the s2 subunit has less
mutation
we can map this these mutations onto the
structure of this
uh protein data bank id pdb
6vxx and kind of see visually
that the distribution is not random so
there is some pattern and that's really
what is
interesting about this is what is the
pattern
and what is shaping the pattern of
distribution of these mutations
to understand how can similar
events as we go through this uh pandemic
how can uh we kind of anticipate what's
going to happen and how can we detect
this early on
to be prepared to what's um going to
happen
so let's think about the selective
pressures
that this virus is undergoing
because right here you can see kind of a
nice
chart that was published not so long ago
where you can see the different
regions so the different genes on the
genome and the
synonymous and non-synonymous mutations
and you can see that
orf 1a for example has the majority of
these mutations right so the y-axis is
the number of mutations and these are
the individual genes
so the first type of uh
kind of a selective pressure that we
know of is
rendezvous and just in general
anti-viral so how does
it lambda severe work it's um
a drug that is going to interfere with
the
rna polymerase or drp and
these antivirals essentially they are
intended to
stop the ability of the virus to
replicate right so if the virus actively
replicates
rendezvous is supposed to reduce that
number but
at the same time it has kind of a
negative effect
why because the rdrp
is um can mutate right so in order to
evade this pressure
and you can see right here an example
from a publication
where such mutations were observed
essentially developing resistance
to this antiviral so that's one type of
pressures
the second one is interferon so because
there is kind of a balance that
ultimately
is the most beneficial to the virus
where the host doesn't die
the host continues to live but also the
pressure
is not strong enough to eliminate the
viral population so
when that balance is achieved right that
is kind of the optimal situation for the
virus but right now
there is the strong immune response we
know that the virus is
actively trying to control this immune
response
and and so there is some optimization
still
in that process and so that's another
kind of theoretically evolutionary
process
or a pressure for the virus to achieve
optimal balance with the immune response
and then um the long-term immunity right
so the antibodies
is another kind of a pressure so the
evasion
of this immune response of detection and
kind of a long-term sustained
recognition of the virus is another
major pressure so these three pressures
and we'll talk in the end of how they
relate to actual uh vaccine rollout
um are kind of strong theoretically
uh pressures that we should observe in
the uh virus so let's see whether this
has really been seen
so the first thing that we talked about
is
uh rambesvir the way it happens
is it actually interacts here with the
rdrp so
after the virus has entered the cell and
the rdrp has been produced it blocks it
and so
that replication of subgenomic
transcription does not happen and so
what happens is that it blocks a
particular
binding pocket and as a result that
pocket becomes the region of active
mutations and so you can see here
a paper that was uh recently published
where
emerging star scope 2 mutation hot spots
including novel rna dependent on a
polymerase variant so rdrp
mutations and so here you have
the treated versus the untreated
samples and you can see that
specifically
in the treated ones there is
this kind of more narrow distribution of
these mutations which
it indicates that you know on average
there's a rate of mutation that happens
throughout the whole
rdrp and then when we look at this
particular pressure it is more selective
and so this is
um again it has not necessarily been
um studied extensively in us enough for
us to understand
what might be the rate or at what levels
of
remdissevere use throughout the
population these types of mutations will
occur
but it still allows us to anticipate
what might happen as a result of
antiviral treatment
now um another kind of an aspect that we
talked about was this uh
ability of the virus to evade detection
and one of the ways that it evades
detection is
by these glycogen molecules so
glycosylation
that essentially the spike protein is
covered with glycans
that are preventing accurate detection
of the full protein and to remain
flexible enough to bind to h2 receptor
you can see that
it actually is not covered throughout so
these are mutations
that happen as a result of this changing
dynamic structure
of these glycos that are covering the
whole
um kind of body of this protein so
um there has also been some modeling
done to kind of show us
what that really looks like and so we
are used to see
the spike protein like this in a naked
shape and here you can see a model
computational model
that shows what it looks like when it's
covered with these glycans and so you
can see
how essentially the top this receptor
binding domain
is open and so that's the critical part
for detection
but then a lot of the areas are covered
up with these glycans and that
helps the virus evade immune detection
and so
because of this uh we
know that um this uh you know specific
uh receptor binding domain is so
critical not
only because of the transmission the non
transmission but also um as the vaccines
are being developed to target that
particular domain
so the other studies that also gus has
alluded to
were done with the covalescent plasma so
what is covalescent plasma
essentially it is a plasma collected
from patients that have
already recovered and so that has to do
with the process of disease progression
so in the beginning
there's this acute host response and
then there's this
kind of response that becomes a
long-term response
and after that time after the person
recovers
that plasma could be collected and
essentially those antibodies are
could be used as a prophylactic or as a
treatment
and so here there is a study that was
done
again the study is not conclusive in the
sense that it was not
done in animal models or patients
but it has been observed so here you can
see
the x-axis is time in days
so from 0 to 100 days and
here you can see how these mutations
are starting to occur based on a number
of kind of variations that were done
in the cell culture experiment where
different dosages were administered for
a long time and so here you can see
different types of mutations and
deletions
that come out seemingly as a response of
administration of this plasma now one of
the things that
i think it's very nice to understand as
you're thinking about these mutations
is what is the actual structural
interaction between these
um antibodies and the spike protein
so there's actually a
pdb structure that was published that
kind of shows
us exactly how that works so here you
can see
this um so again here it's showing
the antigen binding fragments so there's
the light chain um and so
the this is the outside and uh
so the antibody essentially is blocking
is keeping this protein inactive
by uh blocking these receptor binding
domains in a way that they cannot access
and bind to
the ac2 receptors so i think this is why
it's so important for us to link the
mutation data and the sequencing data
with the structural component because we
can really understand how these
interact so it's really nice to have
such models
so this particular antibody is called
ey6a
it was retrieved from an individual
convalescing from covid19
and what they have done in the study is
they have shown that it neutralizes
source code 2 and cross reacts with
source code 1. so it's actually working
with both
both stars 2 and stars 1. it binds to
the receptor binding domain of the viral
spike glycoprotein
tightly and the complex
identifies the highly conserved epitope
away from the h2 receptor binding site
residues within this footprint are key
to stabilizing the pre-fusion spike so
again
how effective is this going to be this
um is actually a question right because
the
regulation of how the spike protein
opens up
and how different portions of it are
accessible and recognizable
is going to play a role in how this
evolves over time
so now another example i think is
to what gus alluded to here
about these quasi species or essentially
how instead of what we think of one
single genome in the host essentially
this is a whole population
or a swarm of competing
virus genomes that are
essentially suppressed by this more
dominant more
effective genome and so what has been
shown
fairly clearly is that most mutations
are um cleared out and so the
genome is fairly stable not because
there are no
other variants out there the population
is very diverse
but the other kind of variants that are
present in that
population are easily cleared out and so
one
key reason for that is because the
infection itself is fairly short so
they don't stay in one host for a very
long time
but as that time grows
that's where you can start observing
how this population really works and so
what they've done here
is actually this is a i'm going to talk
about a combination of two different
studies
one study was with uh immune
so people that have a poor immune
response
um and the other one is with people that
have
this prolonged chronic uh condition
and eventually are treated with
convalescent plasma
so here this
shows the quasi species generation
so the wild type source cove2 which is
the most common form
serves as the reference rna sequence for
development
of an assay but we can see that this
essentially represents a whole kind of
you know each one of these clades here
represents a population essentially and
you can see here individual patients so
individual patients
are going to be um are going to be shown
here
and you can see that some of them become
outliers and so what does it mean that
they are outliers essentially by
themselves
that means that they have some
established
strain from this population that
previously has not been the dominant
strain
and so when they wanted to characterize
what this these strains look like they
started looking
at specific mutations in the spike
glycoprotein
because the only way to treat these
people that have this infection for a
long time
is to administer them with convalescent
plasma from recovered patients
and so here you can see how these
specific mutations
including in the rdp rbd domain
in the fusion peptide in the heptad
repeat
right and then more importantly they
actually correspond
with the epitopes that are recognized by
the different
antibodies so this is one reason
why prolonged infection and seemingly
effective care
with multiple ways to intervene in the
disease actually could also
bring out through selective pressure
some of the
less dominant substrates that all of a
sudden
are not being captured in that treatment
right so the treatment
kind of suppresses the major dominant
strains and these other
uh clades these other quasi species
have more freedom to replicate and
become established and so
that in itself prolonged treatment
comorbidities
and uh the treatments with antivirals
and convalescent plasma
could lead to that effect now another
implication of that and this was
proposed this is a hypothetical
is that you know theoretically
non-hispanic whites and african
americans might have
differences because of similar
properties right so here we see
comorbidities longer time different
types of immune responses
and because of that this kind of change
in the balance of the dominant
kind of quasi species could result in
uh lower detection and essentially a
higher
mortality rate so this was a model that
somebody proposed
now already gus mentioned here that
there was there were additional studies
on cell cultures and
the object objective of this study here
to show here
is that multiple uh mutations
occur at the same time and so you can
see here mutations
in this in the e and the n protein you
can see a mutation in the rdrp
and you can see multiple mutations in
orf1a
and these mutations actually happen in
different patterns
at different days and so one of the
studies wanted to see
what is the again structural component
of these mutated regions
and what they have discussed discovered
is that
one of them is directly related to
resistance to antibodies because they
examined a published spike
uh structure and kind of annotated with
the residues
and it showed that some of these
mutations happen
in a disordered glycosylated loop at the
very tip of the
um at the very tip right here of the ntd
and therefore could alter binding of
antibodies
the other mutation right here is close
to the binding site of the
coronal antibodies derived from co57
plasma 6 plasma and
also you can see that a lot of these
mutations essentially interact with
these antibodies
so what we can understand from here
is one that the longer
the disease the more
these mutations occur at multiple
regions at the same time and i think
another
interesting thing that you can see here
is that there are
there are not only mutations but there
are also deletions
so another thing that i think was
overlooked
in the literature there's a lot of
conversation about different mutations
emerging
and being established in these clades
but
not a lot of people are looking at
multi-nucleotide deletions so not just
deletions
of single nucleotides but deletions that
are longer so here you can see some
examples
so in the beginning what happened was in
this study um the researchers were
trying to identify uh deletions that are
more than a single nucleotide and you
can see
here some shorter examples but you can
also see right here
this is deletion length and this is
number of events so if you just take all
of the publicly available data
what is the distribution of deletion
links
and here you can also see that they have
annotated specific recurring deletions
that are more than a single nucleotide
and uh where they also happen right so i
think this is very interesting because
um there is this um kind of a naturally
occurring
phenomenon where whole portions of
important genes could be deleted from
the viruses
and essentially that is a part of this
quasi-species dynamic where
defective genomes that might have a
profound effect on how these proteins
are actually produced
start interacting with the wild-type
genomes
and so this is a part that i think is
going to be more and more
um explored because essentially what it
shows us
is that we don't even know what other
members of the quasi species are out
there this
is very poorly annotated and very poorly
studied
and at the rate of infection and as we
see the number of established clades
grow
and as we see the number of mutations in
various regions grow
what it leads us to believe is that even
though
the current vaccine is going to be
and you know there are studies ongoing
right now to demonstrate whether it will
be
effective it's probably going to
go from very high rates of effectiveness
and that will go down but the good side
is that really these vaccines
the mrna vaccines at least and the
vaccines that are being produced kind of
using
this you know novel technology are
also much easier to manipulate and so
continuous surveillance of these
viruses especially using deep sequencing
to reveal the low frequency mutations
continuous monitoring of how this
kind of happens within patients that we
start to developing a sense of what
happens
in different cases in different clinical
scenarios
as well as ability to understand the
implication the functional implication
of these different mutations
and to be able to design new versions of
the vaccine right so
i think that you know most of us at
least i
had this anticipation that the vaccine
will be a final solution there will be
kind of a resolve of this pandemic and
you know it seems like
this is not necessarily true and there
there's a lot more research there's
going to be needed
to continue and explore how the dynamic
of this virus is going to continue and
change
especially after such widespread
vaccination
so before we conclude and go on to the
questions
i briefly wanted to mention that these
examples that we've introduced today
are essentially examples that we will
cover
in detail in the upcoming bioinformatics
for infectious disease
graduate course at lsu which is also
going to be available for lbrn so
this is something that you can learn
more about on this link and i'm going to
just paste this link in the chat box
and this program is essentially
designed to introduce biologists and
you know those that are interested in
such research
to be efficient with the data that's out
there that is being generated
with asking questions about the data and
being able to find
evidence in the data itself
to understand different methods of
analysis i think
what we can see from some of the
examples that we presented today
is that it's not just you know the same
method that solves
all the questions really this is a
combination of a variety of different
methods and that includes
sequence alignment that includes
evolutionary
studies that allow us to understand
relationships between
viruses and there are a lot of different
methods for that that include
a variety of different questions that
could be asked it's working with the
structural
proteins so all of the visuals of those
proteins
are very easy to produce but they are
very informative when you identify
those important mutations and also
analysis of transcriptomic data so how
is the host responding
for example if we delete a certain
protein or we introduce a mutation how
can we study the results and understand
the structural kind of components and
what is the
functional result of those mutations
um so this program is going to uh help
you understand pathogens and the
diseases that they cause we'll talk
about source code too but we'll also
talk about
other types of pathogens and we'll also
talk about this
pathogen host interaction we'll talk
about different types of
analyses but also where to find data and
how to start your
bioinformatic analysis from data that's
available and also what are some of the
applications of such analysis how can
this analysis can help us
think about the function
how can it help us think about vaccine
design antivirals antibiotics
and how can it help us understand
epidemiological trends and drug
resistance
and also what's important is that we are
going to
actually take examples from the public
domain of data sets that have been
curated with publication so a lot of the
examples that i presented today
the data is available in fact in terms
of
how much data is available there's over
3.5 million viral sequences and over 13
000 genomes out there so it's a
huge variety of data this data is easy
to find and easy to use
and importantly i think since
ebola virus which was really the first
example
when you know immediately almost in real
time so much data has become available
with covet because so much focus on
covalent because
the availability of the sequencing
technologies
that rate of sequencing and availability
of data has
grown many fold and today there are just
for source code too there are over
180 000 sra runs which are fast q files
with a lot of information
in them over 50 000 nucleotide
uh records and so um a lot of this
continues to
kind of accelerate as we speak um
importantly i think that these data sets
can provide
us with important insights and so
specifically we'll look at examples of
how
to correlate genomic diversity with
population for example geographic
location
we'll talk about immune responses and
how to find biomarkers
and we'll also talk about association
between pathogens and the microbiome
and we'll also look at not just the
nucleotide and structure but we'll also
look at pathway analysis and
interpretation and things like that
we'll take a look at different types of
sequencing methods and how
those different sequencing methods
produce different type of data
and different type of data could be
analyzed using different types of
resources
and we'll also introduce you to some of
the typical analyses
without the need to use coding so we'll
do some coding but we'll also
primarily focus on the logic of analysis
so how to ask the right question
how to find the right method for
analysis and
also how can multiple methods of
analysis could be combined together
to really develop a sense of what's
going on in these complex relationships
like quasi species and hepatitis
or the emergence of more differential
mutations or less differential mutations
and how can we think about asking those
right questions
and answering them with the correct
methods
so we have prepared a number of kind of
curated projects as i mentioned
that will explain some of these for both
asynchronous
and in-person sessions that we'll do on
zoom just like this
and we'll also be able to share those
for further study after that and so an
important part that
i wanted to mention is that all of these
program resources are going to be
available
not just for this graduate course but
also for the louisiana biomedical
research network so the louisiana
biomedical research network
will offer a lot of these resources
as a synchronous resources for faculty
to use and teach the students and also
to kind of explain how all of this works
we will have we will have a special
program
that's going to last for uh from now all
the way until the summer
where you can have access to 16
different hands-on asynchronous courses
the cloud research tools uh some coding
practical tools in r and python
and online support from instructors and
um
i just wanted to make sure that we kind
of cover
all of these options and in maybe the
future
we'll also introduce in greater detail
specifically
what will the structure of the programs
be like
and how these programs can help faculty
graduate students as well as
undergraduate students
so at this point i'm going to pause and
just see if there are
any questions so again
i will i will read out some of the
questions that are
available right here in the chat
okay so um cerise is asking what percent
of the viral
genome needs to be changed mutated for a
strain to be typically considered
a quasi species
um so gus would you like to answer that
or do you want me to
answer you know you could take a shot at
this and i could add to this if you want
like
okay so the um idea behind quasi species
is to identify so if you imagine a fast
q file and has a variety of reads and
we're talking about here whole genomes
is to identify
groups so it's not necessarily
how many mutations right so specifically
when we talk about quasi species
it's the detection of those and grouping
them by similarity
so what could be found is for example
mutations that are in close proximity in
one
region right and there's a lot of them
or you can find many of them distributed
throughout the genome
so it's not the number it's more how do
they form groups because
the main thing here is to differentiate
between
errors in sequencing and some technical
variants
as opposed to actual biological
representative
of a genome that is
potentially in this sample
did you want to answer that guess yeah
so basically
quasi species is really dependent
on the replication kinetics um so if you
look at cell culture
what we've done with bovine corona uh
and
doctor vladimir jenko looked at that if
you look at the level of mutations of
the subgenuine messages
actually quite higher than what you see
the genome as elia
mentioned because they're selected out
for stability purposes of the genome
level
so there is a real swarm of viruses but
most of them are really on
lower they're selected out so they're
predominant
variants of predominant genotypes versus
minor genotypes but because of this
swarm
being available based on some selection
in cell culture in the absence of an
external selection
you're going to get a virus which would
be much easier to replicate
so it may not need specific functions so
you
are prone to get more deletions and for
non-essential genes
because the virus is optimizing its
genotype to really replicate efficiently
in cell culture
without having to worry about
immunological
function and specifically for african
green monkey cells
which are interferon type one interferon
negative there's no even interferon
involvement so basically you're going to
see certain variants
be selected because of the fact that
there's no interference around that
perhaps would influence the application
but i think the the point to be to
impress
is that um the virus has quasi species
swamped the viruses in addition to
mutational rates
on the rna dependent polymerase uh
so it would be quite easy for new
variants to be created
as elia mentioned um based on
even longer infections so the longer the
infection the higher the chance
of a variant to be selected and
this is the issue because typically in
cysco2
you may have two to 14 days
up to three weeks from primary infection
to show symptoms the virus could
replicate
for up to two three weeks and you may
the virus may be
around for months before it gets
eliminated by the immune system
in which case by the time uh the end
result
would be that the virus could be
transmitted in an altered form
to a subsequent person especially from
those shatters
that have virus for a long time
okay so if there is hopefully okay yeah
so she said thank you
and uh i do want to mention about quasi
species because i think this is a
fascinating uh
question in terms of the vaccines right
so as we think about this
um one of the methods that i had a
chance to work with was called surseq
and back then it was applied to polio
and dengue viruses but
the what it reveals is kind of like a
fitness
landscape uh of how
the virus kind of selects
the dominant genome that we essentially
sequence right so when we sequence
the majority of the sequencing
information is going to come from that
dominant
kind of genome but if we had a lower
detection limit so the rate of errors
would be lower then we could pick up
these lower
frequency mutations and if we do we
could study the landscape to understand
which ones are more likely
to be beneficial sort of for the viral
replication for the
overcome of these immune pressures etc
so i think one of the
opportunities here with these novel
sequencing technologies the longer reach
the lower error rates
the novel library preparation techniques
is really an opportunity to survey
the population in much greater detail
and perform these experiments to
understand
what's the logic behind the emergence of
some of these
uh low frequency mutations that already
exist in the population right they're
not necessarily new mutations they just
become
more detectable as we um
see the whole population kind of changed
because of these pressures
and as eli mentioned the issue with
vaccines especially the physio vaccine
which is only the rbd domain
obviously you do have potent
neutralizing antibodies created as well
as cd4 cda t
cells because their epitope's there
but it's very possible that the efficacy
of this vaccine
will wane with time it's not going to be
as bad as flu vaccines because of
a genetic diversity and reassortment but
you will be variants created then the
the end point would be that those
vaccines could be efficacious at 50
or less which require an adjustment
on probably on a yearly basis or even
earlier having a vaccine that may
then target a new genotype
all right great so i know that we went a
little bit over time already
so we're not going to make it too long
it's already 4 20
4 30 almost on friday so
thank you everyone for joining today we
will
follow up we have most of your
registration information for this
webinar so we will follow up with some
more
information about these upcoming
programs
and we will probably have another
webinar about the
specific program structure right for
louisiana biomedical research network
and others and i do want to mention i
see that some people are asking here in
the chat privately
that um we have some other similar
programs that essentially are ongoing at
university of ghana
um and uh with some other universities
so we'll share that information with you
um by email and then for the lbra
network you'll find this information on
the lbrn website
um although they may not be enrolled to
your actual credit course right